[Applaudissements]
dirige depuis 2012 les gymnastes de
haute performance du club unidim qui
compte près de 7000 membres une
quinzaine de parents anciens athlètes et
entraîneurs dénoncent notamment des
épisodes à léguer d'abus verbale d'abus
physiques et de non-respect d'un
protocole de blessure cette ancienne
gymnastique aurait subi les foudres de
l'entraîneur chef à plusieurs occasions
entre 2012 et 2017 il m'a pris les par
les cheveux puis il m'a déposé sur une
autre athlète parce qu'il était fâché
Francis Tessier fait partie d'un groupe
de plusieurs entraîneurs qui ont
démissionné au cours des dernières
semaines en raison du climat jugé
malsain il dit avoir été témoin de
l'incident c'est pas pour placer un
mouvement ou corriger une position que
des millions de façons de faire ça
autrement les enfants qui se font crier
après des enfants qui se font dire des
mauvais mots a aussi quitté le navire
parce qu'elle n'en pouvait plus tout
comme sa collègue Geneviève champagne
j'ai vu des gymnaste à faire humilier
ridiculisé devant les autres
Radio-Canada a pris qu'une ça a été
déposé l'automne dernier à l'officier
des plaintes du Québec contre
l'entraîneur chef l'audience n'a
toujours pas eu lieu devant le comité de
protection de l'intégrité
n'a pas donné suite à nos demandes
d'entrevue c'est le vice-président du
conseil d'administration du nigim parce
qu'elle Croteau qui a répondu à nos
questions pour le club tous les membres
sont au courant ils confirme que
plusieurs allégations contre
l'entraîneur chef sont connus depuis
environ un an mais soutient ne pas
pouvoir en discuter en raison du
processus confidentiel en cours
j'accepterais pas qu'un
entraîneur ou qui compte tire les
cheveux de ces de mes enfants ça c'est
certain mais on parle d'allégation qu'on
doit investiguer de manière rigoureuse
l'entraîneur aurait aussi contrevenu au
protocole de commotion cérébrale à au
moins une occasion selon nos sources une
gymnaste qui était tombée sur la tête
aurait été forcé de reprendre
l'entraînement sur le champ j'ai entendu
si tu veux t'entraîner avec les grandes
tu vas retourner en arrière de la ligne
tu vas recommencer
si tu veux faire le bébé comme tu fais
présentement tu vas aller à l'hôpital
une idée m'affirme avoir offert des
séances de sensibilisation et de
formation à ces entraîneurs ces derniers
mois et que les protocoles sont
respectés le club estime que la sécurité
des enfants n'est pas mise à risque on
est aucune recommandations de mettre
l'entraîneur chef de ces fonctions
malgré ces allégations des phalins n'a
récemment dirigé l'équipe du Québec au
jeu du Canada unidim dit avoir confiance
que la lumière soit faite au comité de
protection de l'intégrité et affirme
qu'il va appliquer ces recommandations
ici Jonathan Jobin Radio-Canada Gatineau